from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell your host joined today
by best-selling author and ramsay
personality christina ellis and we are
excited to take your calls on life and
money and student loans because that's
what's on your mind most likely the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
all right christina last week was just
bananas and you were doing a whole bunch
of media around this whole student loan
forgiveness issue what is the kind of uh
the take of the landscape as you've been
doing media oh it's been wild there has
been so many emotions so many questions
obviously a lot of people were waiting
for this decision it's been pushed down
the road since march 2020 and a lot of
people have been feeling anxiety and
concern
an announcement was finally made and
it's just kind of had emotions all over
the place a lot of people are
obviously happy if you got your loans to
forgiven i'm sure you're happy there's a
lot of people who are excited and
celebrating and there's a lot of people
who are pretty angry i actually posted
something on my instagram asking for
people's feelings about it seeing how oh
boy
dangerous i know it was dangerous i got
i got a lot of interesting comments um
but probably about 80 percent of people
who responded were pretty upset about it
they
either you know paid off their loans or
they went to college debt-free they
worked really hard to go to college
debt-free maybe they didn't go to
college they based their career decision
out of you know not wanting to take out
loans and now they're like oh man this
is a huge thing not only
in um that's not what they believed was
going to happen to begin with but also
for the taxpayer dollars how's it going
to get paid for there's just a ton of
emotion around this topic right now yeah
i saw a video that was going viral it
was an older one maybe from 2020
elizabeth warren and this father came up
to her and said hey i've got a question
for you i worked my tail off to pay for
my daughter to go to college am i going
to get
forgiveness am i going to get money out
of this she said of course not and so he
was going into this my buddy was sitting
here being lazy not doing anything and
he's going to have his loans forget and
so there's all there's a lot of uproar
about this and there's a lot of good
reasons on both sides for people to be
happy for people to be upset but i want
to go over in case you've been living
under a rock and just go over the facts
of what we know because right now
there's it feels like there's more
questions than answers right and so if
you don't know president biden announced
student loan forgiveness ten thousand
dollars for folks making up to 125 or if
you're filed uh married filing jointly
250 k is the limit
and if you received a pell grant it's up
to 20 000 which i am actually for
because the pell grant is for those
lower income folks who couldn't afford
to go to college at all and so that one
i i'm a big fan of and the moratorium on
student loans now ends on the payments
ends december 31st so they kick that can
down the road no payments no interest
till the new year and then there was
also changes based uh to the income
based repayment program and so they're
capping at five percent of income
instead of ten so a lot of big changes
there that's the news without any spin
there uh but the question is are these
changes finalized yeah that's a big
question that i feel like a lot of
people aren't talking about a lot of
people are celebrating right now but
it's important to realize that a lot of
these changes could be challenged i mean
biden put this out there and it could be
challenged because a lot of people are
wondering can he do that can he do this
without going through congress is it
going to be challenged by congress the
supreme court um yeah there's just a lot
of space and room for things to be
changed so you know hold it slightly
loosely i know that's hard to say for
somebody who's really counting on this
forgiveness but just realize a lot of
this stuff isn't finalized especially
some of the details so
if you're waiting on forgiveness you can
sign up at studentaid.gov
subscriptions to get updates on the
regular they also promise that more
details will be released in the next few
weeks so of course we'll keep people
posted as we find out more yes and of
course everyone's first thought was well
how much is that going to cost
and the two it's up to the tune of about
300 billion dollars
and that's just a ballpark number and
then you go well how many taxpayers are
there if that's who the burden is going
to fall on about 144 million taxpayers
which equates to about two thousand
dollars a person just on napkin math
so that takes your breath away a little
bit to go we're gonna forgive 10 but
that's going to put two on every single
tax paying american which is part of the
outrage and again we don't know how this
is going to be paid for if it is going
to be through taxes they're saying you
know of course the white house is saying
no no we're not going to raise taxes
it's going to come from the deficit that
we're going to create in other areas and
so i'll believe it when i see it but
that's that's the numbers which is kind
of crazy because like an individual we
couldn't just be like hey i have a
present for you i have no idea how i'm
going to pay for it but you know here it
is and i think that's the question i
keep getting is how's this going to be
paid for how is this going to be covered
and it's not entirely clear but people
are
feeling a little nervous another piece
of the puzzle here is what is this going
to do to the cost of college which has
already skyrocketed and now it feels
like colleges are going to be like oh
sweet now's our chance to raise the
price even more well and that's the
challenge is that it doesn't really
address that they say that they want to
control the cost of college but there's
not a lot of specifics for how that's
going to actually happen they say they
want accountability but we need college
costs to really be controlled because
typically if loans are more available
colleges will take advantage of that and
especially with these new income based
repayment guidelines it could really
embolden people to take out more student
loans if they're saying now that this is
going to be capped at five percent of
your income it could be easy for
students to say well hey if it's it's
going to be five percent of my income
why not take out a bunch of student
loans because after college i'm only
gonna have to pay for up to five percent
so what does it matter if i take out
fifty thousand or a hundred thousand and
that's really concerning because that's
still going to be a challenge to pay
back that is still
dead and i think it's just really
challenging because we already have a
struggle with 18 year olds taking out
student loans a lot of times they don't
understand what that feels like after
graduation to pay back and now with
these rules changing it's just really
concerning for one what it could do for
the cost of college if colleges are
going to raise prices as a result of
that and two just if students are truly
going to understand that this debt is
not something they should take on
and another piece of the puzzle is the
anger of people who are going well i
paid off my student loans what about me
and so the good news for those folks is
that if you made payments during after
the pause
then they're saying you're going to get
a refund and that's directly from the
u.s department of education and i did
find out how these refunds are currently
working and this is based on someone
saying here's what my student loan
servicer told me so the student loan
companies are not just writing you a
check what they're doing is they're
taking your zero balance and reverting
it back to ten thousand dollar balance
ouch so you're going back into debt
within the hope that the government will
eventually forgive that
so that's what's actually happening no
one is just cutting checks going here
you go here's your money back they're
just reverting the balances and then
saying now you can wait to see what the
government does wow and i've had a lot
of questions from people saying you know
i did pay on my loans during the
pandemic should i seek out that refund
or not and i mean i say it's really up
to you a lot of people that i've talked
to don't want to get that refund because
they felt like it was their student loan
they paid it off and they're proud of
that and we've also told people that if
you do get that refund like it's okay
there's nothing wrong with that it's
just really what helps you sleep better
at night you know whatever is going to
make you feel more at peace that's
really
what you got to do but i'll be honest i
feel like ten thousand dollars would
make me sleep pretty good at night so
if it's you know if you're in my shoes
i'd be taking it if i had paid it and
i'm going sweet it's the exact same
thing as taking advantage of you know a
stimulus check for example that's
something where the government was
saying here's the money and we go okay i
don't even if you don't agree with it
you're still going to take the money and
apply it to your financial journey and
that's great
yeah i think i've talked to a lot of
parents too though that they're they're
worried about the national debt they're
worried about this burden going on to
their kids and so i think just out of
principle they're kind of saying i don't
want to but really i mean you could go
either way but the bottom line is we're
all sleeping better when we're debt-free
and so make that a priority in your life
no matter how you got to do it as long
as it's legal okay folks don't get it
don't get any ideas here don't be shady
hey folks more of your calls coming up
triple eight eight two five five two two
five i'm george campbell she's christina
ellis this is the ramsay show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined today by
christina ellis this is the ramsey show
open phones triple eight eight two five
five two two five yousef joins us in
detroit michigan detroit uh yusuf
welcome to the ramsay show what's up
hey how you guys doing great how can we
help today
yeah so i guess this is uh kind of
similar to student loans but not exactly
so
uh i graduate undergrad in december uh i
have about 20 000 right now in student
loans
and i'm looking to go to med school next
year hopefully
uh and so
i know uh dave and some of you other
guys have uh answered questions about
how to finance or no i know how to
finance do you guys don't agree with
mine on how to pay for med school
however uh when it comes to like
scholarships from the schools or whatnot
i don't really have any outstanding
academic achievement or athletic
achievement so
it's like almost 99 sure i'm gonna have
to take out loans now here's the bulk
part of my question
due to uh religious reasons any interest
on loans is like a kind of a no-no
whether it's paying interest or
collecting any interest payments and so
for faith-based reasons uh you know i
don't think i would at all feel
comfortable whether even if it's federal
loans or private loans because there's
no way i would pay it back quickly
enough and that interest doesn't accrue
so i guess
it's a two-part question uh one what
would you say is the best way to pay for
med school if it's someone like me who
doesn't have like a 4.0 and the best
grades in the world and the best you
know mcat scores and whatnot but also
that's the first part and then the
second part is you know if
where it's most likely gonna happen i'm
gonna have to take out loans
is there any kind of organization or
any way that you guys know of that i
could get some kind of interest free
loans if i need to take one out for
school
i'm gonna let christina run with this
one first and then i'll give you my take
yeah that's a that's a great question i
know med school is a challenging one we
get this question quite a bit because it
is a
beast to try to tackle sometimes when
you're trying to pay for it um a lot
like you said some of these scholarship
programs are pretty competitive um but
one of the very first things you can
look with med school that i think a lot
of people overlook is your school
selection there are med schools that are
super expensive and there are some that
are a bit cheaper so the very first spot
i would look at is what is the cheapest
med school i can go to that i'm still
going to have a great degree and be able
to graduate debt-free
obviously you can work while you're in
med school i know it's a very tough
program so that can be kind of hard
but try to work and pay as you go and
then another great option is the
military or some sort of commitment
program where of course you're you're
basically committing that you're going
to work for a certain period of time but
they pay for your education and you get
experience as you go
now when it comes to the question about
zero interest loans
i'm not familiar with any of them
obviously there's some different
foundations and organizations to do
scholarships and fellowships but
typically when somebody is giving out a
loan they have they have a motive like
they want they're in it to make money
right they want to make money so i think
that part might be tough to find but i
think you can still be really strategic
in figuring out how to go debt-free
what's your take george uh i totally
agree if this is something that is
against your you know religious beliefs
uh then you gotta say i gotta find
another way and that might mean being
creative it might mean delaying med
school um you said you've got 20k in
debt right now
what is the urgency to go to med school
could you work for a while and then save
up and cash flow it
ah
i suppose i mean i haven't really
thought about it like that however
you know the minimum you know even in
public interest you know i'm in michigan
even the minimum public in state med
school is going to cost around about
like 40k a year and so 40 times 4 gets
me 160 and me or my parents don't and i
don't know how long
i only have like a well in december i'll
have a bachelor's of science in
neuroscience so it isn't exactly a
degree in which i can go and get like a
high five figure job right out the gate
so
i it wasn't something that i thought
about i did think about something called
the
md phd program where essentially you get
both an md degree and a phd degree
however it's double the length so
instead of four years it's eight years
however it's free actually you get a
stipend you get paid so i i've been
thinking about that but i haven't
actually never thought of just delaying
it and just try to save up no
i mean if you can get into one of those
md phd programs it's incredible and it
will take longer but you also will leave
there making an incredible income and
zero payments well one of the challenges
with the md phd program is you did say
that you're you're more of an average
student um and don't really have any
standout achievements those are pretty
competitive programs to get into they're
they're similar to getting a competitive
scholarship or a competitive fellowship
that being said you may want to try for
it regardless i'm all about shooting for
the stars and and giving it a shot i
mean you don't have anything to lose by
trying um but those are typically pretty
competitive and with going with what
george was saying about potentially
working first a lot of hospitals have
programs with tuition assistance so
maybe you could even find a hospital
where you can work in a research lab and
potentially have them pay for part of
your education as you move forward i
think one of the biggest things is just
being really creative and strategic i
love that you're saying hey i am not
going to take out a loan with interest
like that is a hard line and i think
whenever you make that hard line in the
sand and you say hey i'm not doing this
no matter what happens no matter what
the cost you're more likely to be
strategic i love that you're even
calling into the show because that means
you're thinking outside the box and
you're thinking what can i do but you
know look into
how do you feel about possibly going
into the military or serving in that way
uh
um i've looked you know okay so i'll say
this i'm a dual canadian american
citizen and so i could technically would
be well i'm only applying to med school
here in the states however
you know i guess my biggest fear would
be just you know actual deployment like
you know regardless you know let's say
i'm in med school the next four years
and you know all of a sudden boop we're
going to war uh like again i
it's something that i thought of but i'm
just way too scared however you did
mention something about hospitals and
ping i have over a thousand hours of
research i have three publications
and so i actually didn't know that if i
there are some hospitals here in the
country i'm not sure where exactly but i
didn't know that there are some
hospitals that will
help pay your tuition i didn't know that
yeah yeah i've talked to some students
who've worked through it that way but
hey you just said you have three
publications and a thousand hours you've
already done that's impressive i'd hire
this guy right that's amazing i'm like
hey you do still need to go for these
fellowships and these scholarships
because that is impressive
thank you uh
yeah i guess i guess for me that the the
best thing to do right now is i guess
first of all get accepted because you
know
go from you know i need to go to med
school first to even think about how i'm
going to pay for it and then or i may
have to just end up waiting a year and
then applying for 2024 and hopefully
i can find one of these programs or work
at a hospital with a research lab
that'll help finance or help pay an
exchange that i would do in my residency
or i would work for them after residency
something like that but that's something
to look into
uh yeah could you retake the mcat as
well
i get my mcat score tomorrow ooh
all right fingers crossed man
that that could be a big help
for sure in getting into a more
affordable school getting any kind of
scholarship i know it's tough i'm not i
don't want to just belittle the
situation it's very difficult yeah cash
flow at school we're not trying to
pretend like there's a magic wand you
can oh it's just easy just apply for
some scholarships but also if i decide
tomorrow that i want a 500 000 house
it's going to be hard to afford it when
i just decided right so a part of this
conversation is you know going all right
i want to go to med school it may need
to be four years from now to where i can
cash flow this experience because i have
family members who have done that and
they went all right i'm going to be a
nurse for the next five years and then
i'm going to go to med school i'm going
to be a nurse practitioner wait a few
years get some experience
make some money and then go to med
school and uh what you don't want to do
is go i'm just gonna go 300 000 into
debt at whatever school i get into and
i'll figure it out later right because
we have seen some doctors in some
serious debt and it's like even though
they have the great income they are
feeling incredible weight and anxiety so
you don't want to just go that that
route and it may be delayed ratification
you may have to work like you said four
years do something else but that that
extra little time can pay off huge in
the long run i know in med school alone
i mean you're like okay so eight years
from now i can be doing this it's a long
journey and it's something you gotta
really commit to it's hard to quit
halfway through and then you feel like i
just wasted a lot of time a lot of sunk
costs fallacy in there so man this is a
big decision but we're pulling for you
and the fact that you even called us
wanting to have this conversation gives
me a lot of hope that you're gonna
figure out a way yousef so thank you so
much for the call keep us posted we'd
love to help along your journey triple
eight eight two five five two let's talk
about your life and your money this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
i'm george campbell host of the fine
print podcast and the entree leadership
podcast joined today by christina ellis
best-selling author and ramsey
personality if you want to check out any
of the shows i mentioned including this
one which you're listening to you can
find them all on the ramsay network or
wherever you listen to podcasts open
phones triple eight eight two five five
two two five julia joins us up next in
hartford connecticut julia welcome to
the show
hi thanks guys for taking my call
my question is i work at a college and
don't get paid a lot and money is very
tight
and my children are 14 15 and one of the
benefits is that they get free college
tuition
so i'm trying to decide do i stay there
for the next eight years or so to get
that benefit or do i leave somewhere and
make more money
that is quite the dilemma so what is the
school cost
tuition alone is 40 000 a semester
today's rates um for both of them to go
four years each and commute it will be
twenty thousand dollars total i'm
divorced so my half would be ten
what is your current pay at this college
it's 40 000.
and what do you how much do you think
you could earn if you work somewhere
else
um i'm going to say
50 to 60.
okay what kind of work are you doing
um i do paperwork in one of the
departments i'm not not a teacher
okay so what and are you saying you'd go
work at another university that would
definitely pay more are you sure of this
um
maybe not necessarily university but um
just another
something else in my field
you said you need paperwork is that
something you could do in the private
sector maybe within a within a
corporation that paid a little bit
higher
yeah okay so the 50 and 60 is also based
on that estimate as well
yes yes because i left a higher paying
job
for this job for the purpose of the
education but now after the divorce
money is very tight and
with my oldest being 15 the other
concern is the child support will get
split in half
and then a year and a half later it'll
be zero
now this this college benefit where they
get you said it's free tuition
is that one of the benefits where it's
it's they're eligible to go anywhere in
the state or is it just at the specific
college
um
this college and then they can take uh
they can go to other colleges and i
believe it would be the same tuition
amount that's credited so tuition's 30
000 they twenty thousand credit
okay
and then tell us more about your kids
what are they kind of thinking about for
the future are they for sure going to
college
um at least in their minds
i mean it changes daily um it could be
an astronaut or a librarian or a bank
robber dolphins
[Laughter]
yeah they they do want to go
my worry is you sacrifice this uh your
career and then they go nah mom i want
to go way over here across the universe
i don't want to go to that school last
night she's very unhappy and they do
they have to apply and get in still
um they're pretty much guaranteed in at
my college if they go through wow the
normal process and
i'm wondering could you leave and then
come back the year before they go to
school or does it not work like that
what is the time
um you have to be full time for five
years and at that point i will have been
in a full-time position there for five
years and i've been there coming at
seven okay
have you
talked to any leadership about the
possibility of moving up within the
college are there any um growth
opportunities with where you're at now
um
it wouldn't be advancement it would be
horizontal
and this is actually um after a pay
raise that i just got
okay do you love what you do
i do
but the money is so tight right now and
you're saying the the child support
would run out
how soon yes
um my oldest is 15 almost 16 so
a couple more years and then what
happens if you're still making the same
salary
um
so my ex-husband is set to retire about
the same time that the kids will
be 18 and hopefully he will retire on
time and then i will collect on his
pension if not
i definitely need a second job or a
different career have you had a
conversation with your ex-husband about
paying for college would he have money
to pay for them if you ended up
switching careers
he would not the money that we did have
saved um was used up by him
so they're zero on
zero in savings on my end well i drained
the college savings for the kids
yes oh my god use it on himself for
school
which would have covered all their costs
that's brutal well yeah here's my thing
i don't want you to suffer for eight
years in order to make this happen
because the truth is they have options
and they have time to work they can cash
flow they can do scholarships and
christina can talk your head off all day
about all the ways they can do that and
so i think
i don't want you to get so you know
tunnel vision on this is the only way
and this is where they're going to go to
school and have that plan fall apart i'd
rather you go work somewhere else love
it and then we figure out a new plan for
how we're going to pay for college
right that's exactly what i was thinking
i don't want to diminish the 40 000 a
year because that is significant however
i do feel confident you can figure out
other strategies to graduate debt-free
um obviously yeah that's where my area
is and i just love talking people
through it because there are so many
options especially nowadays and you have
14 and 15 year olds so if you were
talking you know your kids were in their
senior year and it's it's next year that
we're talking about i'd be a little bit
more nervous for you like let's let's
get going now but at 14 and 15 i mean
that's when my mom talked to me about
going debt free and that gives them time
to really put together a strategy to
start building up their resume
throughout high school to work jobs when
they're in high school to start really
thinking about how they can stand out in
the scholarship application process and
i think if you're less stressed if
you're not feeling that weight of money
worries you're going to have a lot more
time to pour into their lives and to
help them figure out how they can go to
college debt-free i think that's going
to be a win kind of in both directions
they're going to learn a lot through the
process of figuring out how to pay for
their own education and you're going to
feel a lot better being able to provide
for yourself and your family and not
feeling that weight and financial stress
well julie i want to give you two things
before we go here one is ken coleman's
book from paycheck to purpose that's for
you to advance in your career get paid
more do what you love so hang on the
line austin will send you that and we're
also going to gift you a code to watch
borrowed future our documentary on the
student loan crisis with the kids and
then start a game plan start a
conversation for how we're going to do
this thing so hang on the line austin
will pick up we'll get you both of those
david joins us up next in pinehurst
north carolina david welcome to the
hey jordan show how are you guys doing
great how are you good good living
your phone sounds like you're a robot
can you fix that for us
how is that that's a little better
what's going on
so a question for you guys i got a
little bit of context first my wife and
i recently became debt free we're
actually coming on this you know not
tomorrow but the following tuesday to do
our debt free stream oh awesome
congratulations so hopefully get to meet
you guys next week but currently we're
sort of uh working on bugging up our
life insurance we both have insurance
through our employers
term insurance
and we both
work outside the home we have pretty
fairly equal incomes we have one child
we don't own a home we're debt-free now
like i said we both have term policies
here david
so what is your what's your income and
what's her income
uh we're both making about 100 now
each
yes awesome okay and how much is offered
through work
um so we both have about a half a
million dollar policy now okay
so that's a great start but we also we
always say you don't want to rely on
that because if you switch jobs that's
over and you get a restart and now
you're paying a whole lot more to sign
up for term life later in life so you
want 10 to 12 times your income which
for you guys you're looking at you know
a million dollar 1.2 million dollar
policy each and i would just tack that
onto the 500 you already have um it's
not going to cost that much how old are
you two
uh we're both in our mid 30s
mid 30s and both healthy
congress very healthy go jump onto our
website ramsaysolutions.com and click on
trusted pros get connected with xander
and you can actually play around with
those term life quotes online and
they're surprisingly affordable for
young people who are super healthy i'd
go ahead and lock that in now
before you come here for your debt-free
scream that's a huge step you guys are
taking
so george we didn't go through xander
and i guess the question is for us is
that mike my salary is projected to be
probably five to ten fold of what it was
in the next 10 years or 15 years okay so
what would you look out would you
increase the power amount since we're
locking in right now and would you
increase the length of the term based on
you know are being financially stable
now i would still do a longer term since
you guys are younger and you can always
add more later what we did was i got my
new one in place that was cheaper and i
got rid of the old ones sometimes it
makes sense to just add another one on
top of that and you can kind of ladder
it so you can go either way you can do
the math and see what's more affordable
but as long as you've got that in place
you're gonna be debt-free soon man
that's awesome way to go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how many times have you found yourself
saying one day when you're thinking
about a gold that you have one day i'll
be able to buy a house one day i'll be
happy with my career or one day i won't
have to battle with anxiety anymore well
stop waiting around whatever your one
day is you gotta start now that's why we
created smart conference it's the one
day event get that where we tackle all
areas of your life we could all use that
kind of boost right now you're going to
hear from the nation's top thought
leaders on money career mental health
relationships marriage and leadership
this is like the ramsay buffet this
event is hitting the road we're going to
dallas texas on saturday october 22nd
and event passes are selling fast vip
and platinum already gone sold out but
we still have general access passes for
just 39 bucks for a whole day event
best-selling authors and world-class
speakers include rachel cruz dr john
deloney ken coleman christina ellis dave
ramsey and i'll be there too
in full force guys this is a fun event
and not to mention we've got some
special guests craig and amy grochelle
from life church talking about
leadership and marriage it's gonna be
awesome lots of surprises very
entertaining live music just for 39
bucks you can't beat that christina come
on that's incredible
it's worth traveling a lot of people fly
all over the country to see us uh at
these big arena events so it's worth it
worth the drive worth the flight ramsey
solutions.com events is the place to get
your passes this event is going to sell
out can't wait to see you guys there so
christina before we went into the break
we were talking to our friend who's
coming to do his debt-free scream soon
and he was asking about life insurance
and i wanted to clarify because we ran
out of time and his phone sounded like
he was from outer space
but we say you want 10 to 12 times your
income
in a life insurance plan term life only
no whole life run as far away as you can
from anything that says permanent or
whole life in there
and the reason we say to get a 15 to 20
year term life policy is because if
you're following our plan if you go all
in on this stuff meaning you have a
15-year fixed-rate mortgage you're going
to be self-insured by the time the
policy runs out so you're going well
what about what happens in 15 years
don't i need life insurance you
shouldn't because for 15 years you've
been investing 15 of your income you now
have a paid for house you've tons of
money in the bank tons of money in
retirement no payments which means if
something happened to you which by the
way is the only reason you need term
life don't get this on your one-year-old
they don't need it you do it to replace
income so unless your one-year-old is
crushing the game they don't need life
insurance
then you'll be self-insured after the
term is over so if you're interested in
learning more every single person
needs this if someone relies on their
income so parents this is you spouses
this is you jump on ramseysolutions.com
and connect with our friends at xander
and it is super super affordable to get
term life especially the younger you are
the healthier you are this is super easy
to do and it is worth your time to do it
well i think it's one of those things
that so often it's kind of
easy to not prioritize that it's like
you feel like it's going to be this
thing that's going to take a long time
and you just kind of put it off but this
is something that's so important if
something happens and you have children
do it today this will probably take
about 30 minutes of your time to get on
and and sign up and a lot of them have
no medical exam and you can complete
them online right i chose to have
someone you know someone comes by the
house they take some blood and make sure
that you're in good health but if you've
had recent blood work done a lot of
times they can use that as well so a lot
of options out there so get connected to
them they will find you quotes from the
top rated companies around the country
they're not beholden to one company
which is what we always tell you to do
shop independently to get the best rate
get that in place today all right open
phones triple eight eight two five five
two two five baltimore maryland is where
we're heading next evan joins us there
evan welcome to the show
hey how you guys doing we're doing great
how can we help
so i'm 21 years old me and my wife just
had our first child congrats
thank you thank you and um we i work for
the railroad railroad i'm a fourth
generation railroader wow
yeah
i'm on track to make a hundred thousand
this year you know and uh my wife wants
to know we should be pocketing any money
aside from 401k setup even though he had
the rare attention
um
so uh in
in reality i've seen two
sets of grandparents retire on the
railroad right now off of this railroad
pension and they're not hurt for money
and they never invested because we don't
get any any match whatsoever because of
the retirement i don't collect social
security on this retirement either
um so basically it's just investing
money for ourselves in the future
whatever we want but my question is
should i be
what is the details of the pension is
this mandatory are you contributing
anything
yes i contributed about 30 of my
paycheck
wow that's a big chunk no wonder you can
retire
now
well
i'm going to be paying it for the next
40 or 38 years we've already invested
four
um
so i mean should i invest in a 401k i
mean in all reality wouldn't that just
be like money set aside for our like
as play money so to speak
i mean it never hurts to do more but we
only want you to do more than 15 after
you are in baby step 7 which means you
have a paid for house do you guys have a
paid for house
no i still uh 140. okay so here's how we
look at pensions um because they they're
finicky you don't have control over it
but if you are making mandatory
contributions from your own paycheck
meaning the company isn't paying in you
are we can't that we count that at about
half so you told me they're making you
contribute 30 percent
yes i have my tier so i it's a two-tier
system i have my peer and then she has
her so i pay in full and i basically pay
half of what i put in for mine for her
so she basically she gets a pension it's
like one and a half oh interesting
well if you're telling me 30 we would
count that at half at 15 which means
you're right on track so you would not
need to contribute any more so i would
then focus all extra money on paying off
that house early and saving for college
which you got a newborn so you got
plenty of time to cash flow the college
experience
yeah he's 10 months tomorrow oh man what
a bright future and can i just say what
a rock star 21 years old do you have a
college degree
no no never went to college one day boom
that's incredible i think you are a
shining example of the trades and that
there are alternate options to making
incredible income very early on
absolutely do you enjoy what you do evan
i do i love it that's awesome man we're
so pumped for you so yeah i would stay
the course you're already doing that 30
that's plenty right now
once you guys hit baby step 7 you pay
off the house then you can start you
know if you want to fund a roth ira if
you've got other options like a 401k
then i would look into uh alternative
investments like that and that will
allow you to retire early to have i'd
rather have way too much in retirement
than not enough right and at 21 years
old if you walk out this plan if you pay
off the house and then start investing
extra and above i have no doubt y'all
are going to be baby step millionaires
by what 30. oh absolutely that's
incredible incredible
all right leslie joins us up next in los
angeles leslie welcome to the show
hi guys thank you for taking my call i
appreciate it absolutely what's going on
so
um well first and foremost i'm newly
pregnant i'm due in december congrats i
recently thank you i recently just came
across um well not came across my father
my grandfather left me an inheritance of
55 000 plus some cash
so i'm in the process of personally
paying off all my debt i just have my
student loan that'll be paid off by the
end of the month awesome my question is
this because i'm trying to follow the
steps
my husband has no debt except for his
auto loan and then he has we have a
mobile home together that we still owe
money so i'm kind of battling in between
should i pay off his auto loan
or should i go ahead and invest
some of that money
you guys are married so what do i invest
in
so why would you not pay off his auto
loan
um i have to be quite honest i have no
idea i don't know
we've played around with the idea
because we're trying to save all the
money we can so i'm literally just
sitting on this i put it in a high yield
savings and i'm just sitting on it and
he's just like we need to save the money
save the money because of the baby
what's the total amount of all the debt
you have outside of the mobile home
um ten thousand oh write a check and pay
everything off today including the auto
loan what's left on the mobile home
140. okay whatever's left over you can
apply to that and start knocking that
off are you investing 15 of your income
beyond that
um no because i'm unemployed and so i
know that he has his 401k and everything
set up with his job so he's investing in
that but i was wanting to take a little
bit of that cash that i got to invest
but i don't know what to invest in okay
i think it's super important to make
sure you have an emergency fund as well
too so once you get that debt knocked
out we want to have a three to six month
emergency fund and then focus on
investing yeah there's a time and place
for it but if we got to pay off all the
debt then we start investing then we're
focused on paying off the mortgage
thanks so much for the call leslie that
puts this hour of the ramsey show in the
books my thanks to all the folks in the
booth and my co-host christina ellis and
to you america thanks so much we'll be
back with you before you know it
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell host of the fine print
and entree leadership podcast on the
ramsey network joined today by
best-selling author christina ellis and
we are excited to take your calls about
life
money investing emergency funds paying
off debt how to pay for college how to
get rid of student loans you name it we
are here for you america the number to
call is triple eight eight two five
825-5225 melody kicks us off in miami
melody welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
we are happy to take it you are so
excited and we love that for you
awesome so i'm on baby step or we are on
babysit four five and six
and i'm trying to get more refined in
how i do
the collet paying for college i've done
a couple things um
my husband and i have uh like doing
pre-paid tuition which i know you don't
recommend
and we're also within spinning distance
of
um paying off our mortgage so just
trying to refine what i'm doing there
all right how old are the kids
uh 12 and 8.
all right and what's your income
320 before you know gross well that's
great news fantastic income
and where are you guys at currently with
saving for college
well we have um
prepaid tuition which is like a
four-year university plan which the
value of that if we can we can take it
out
is 26k and 27k so it's about the same
and we've got a utma for my son that's
like 10 and a coverdill
and then another 529
which i'm not sure exactly where that is
because i didn't do it that was my
husband
but i gotta look into that um
and then for my my daughter uh who's the
eight-year-old we also have um a utma
and every girl in 529 so total for
my son who's 12. i've got about 40 and
then
plus that prepaid tuition and then for
my daughter's 25 and
the pre prepaid tuition awesome well you
guys are doing great
yeah
are you worried about not being able to
afford it
yeah i mean because i've heard you know
numbers like 180 for each kid and
those kind of numbers i'm wondering if
we can even meet for the 12 year old
and i'm just wondering if i'm being wise
with
you know three years ago i thought okay
babysit five i'm just gonna put it
towards prepaid college and i'll be done
but well that's not exactly
that's not going to pay for much so with
room and board and all that
well yeah like george i think you guys
are doing awesome this is a great start
i'm kind of curious what has been your
process for planning for this have you
all kind of sat down and
projected about how much you think each
college or each student will spend or
what's your process look like
well it's pretty disorganized as you
probably tell
we we've had
various meetings you know what would you
like to do this that or the other thing
and um
we just kind of have done it all um
yeah without
the end goal in mind and that's kind of
where i think where i would start is i
think i think you all are doing well and
i think your heart's in the right place
i think you all are um prepared to plan
but yeah you said it it kind of feels a
bit disorganized and i think that's
where some of that anxiety is coming
from kind of not knowing what the target
is but yet feeling this weight of a
mountain
of college cost in the near future
well how do you determine the target
though i mean i guess the smart investor
pros the way to go but
you know just like yeah so you can go
with the smartmaster pro they can help
you figure out about exactly how much
you need to be saving monthly to get to
around where you want to get but you can
also go online there are a lot of
calculators where you can type in you
know if you if you think your student's
going to go to public school the cost of
public school and then it'll break down
about how much you need to be saving
each year in order to meet that goal and
you can do the same thing with private
school but kind of you know it'll give
you a ballpark so that you can kind of
know how much you
should be contributing monthly and if
you're on track
right so what about this prepaid tuition
thing should i try to get out of that
and try to be more proactive do you know
if there's penalties with that exact
plan
to get out no penalty there's no penalty
it's just you get what you put in um
as long as your kid hasn't gone to
college yet
yeah so i would if you can move that
over to the some of these other ones
like the coverdale 529
i would do that
are you all working with a smart
investor pro right now
no
i would i'm looking at your income and
going wow that's impressive and amazing
and with 320 000 dollars to invest and
kind of figure out what you want to do i
would definitely sit down with somebody
and they can help you get organized with
all these different accounts that you
kind of have outstanding they can help
you figure out you know what's the best
vehicle to save and how much do i need
to be saving um you know each month and
just kind of get organized in your
finances because i think that's where
some of this uh
just like anxiety is coming from i think
you guys are on a great pace especially
with that income um i think you're going
to be able to definitely reach a really
good spot in your college savings um but
i think it'd just be helpful to have a
plan a really clear succinct plan melody
what's left on the mortgage
50. 50. that's amazing yeah i know okay
so just walk this out with me melody
you're going to have a paid for house
within the next year
yes okay so then we still have another
five years for the first kid to even
start college and we're making 320 and
it probably is only going to go up over
the next few years
and you're telling me you wouldn't be
able to cash flow the rest of school if
you had let's say a hundred in there and
school was going to cost 120 for the
four years you guys could cash flow this
easily
really well we were thinking with the
mortgage being paid off but my husband
could get a job that he would love more
and that would kind of give us a little
more do you take a pay cut but he'd
enjoy it
yeah so he doesn't have to worry about
you know
making as much as he needs so you know
he probably will i mean i don't know why
he wouldn't but
i think that's just one of his
um
you know
just a little less stress about how much
of a pay cut are you looking at
um well i mean he could go uh
we we make about the same but he makes a
little more um
uh
because i mean even if he took a forty
or eighty thousand no payments in the
world and you're still making 250 or
220. yeah i mean you can still cash flow
all of this
or something i mean
i i can't imagine still being in the
field and still
you know doing that because he's an
engineer engineering manager
but um
yeah so you're thinking we can just
cashflow the 12 year olds
absolutely
whatever whatever the gap is so let's
you don't again we don't know what
college is going to cost we don't know
what the 12 year old is going to do and
so let's say school's going gonna cost
160 grand and you guys have a hundred by
the time he's 18. right
well at that point we know the gap it's
60 grand and we need to cover that over
the next four years so we need to come
up with 20 grand you know for three
years if we can cashflow the first so i
think we just come up with a plan i
think a smart investor pro is going to
give you a lot of confidence in the plan
and right now it seems like you're doing
17 things at once and just hoping for
the best and i want to give you a little
a little more clarity and this is what
the future is going to look like if we
follow this plan so get connected with
one of ramsaysolutions.com but you guys
are doing great with that kind of income
and the fact that you're already saving
and the kids are young
i think you can breathe easy and sleep
well tonight you guys have done really
well great great work these are the kind
of parents we need in the world
christina right love it this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you that's why you need to get in touch
with churchill mortgage to make sure you
do this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
every time you hear someone do a debt
free scream on the show it's because at
some point they said enough i'm not
living like this anymore i've had it
and when you get mad like that and do
what they did your life will change too
and right now inflation and stupid
credit cards are killing you you've
started to believe that you're not in
control of your money
but you'd be wrong
you get to decide to control what you
can control and that's you the guy in
the mirror the lady in the mirror your
behavior you have the power to change
your future and financial peace
university will show you how this is the
same course i went through almost a
decade ago now that changed the way i
handled money changed the way i looked
at money it's a proven step-by-step plan
that nearly 10 million people have used
to beat debt master budgeting and build
wealth and you can do this too guys stop
letting debt and money stress control
your life just say enough and take back
your control
it's that simple and it's that hard you
can start financial peace university at
ramseysolutions.com slash enough that's
ramsay solutions dot com slash
enough
all right christina you know what time
it is it's time for our blinds.com
question of the day their 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsay to get the best deal
today's question comes from gavin in
ohio i'm 30 years old and i'm thinking
about switching careers i'm an hvac
technician but would like to jump into
the nursing field i like the trades but
it's just hard on your body i was
wondering how a person trying to get
back into college would go about
applying for scholarships it seems like
there are very few scholarships out
there for people changing careers later
in life my wife and i are out of debt
and i don't want to go back into debt
well good for you for starting from that
position i love that you've already put
that line in the sand and you're saying
hey i want to change but i'm not going
to go crazy with and i'm not going to go
into debt to do it
the cool thing is is while while it may
be a little bit more challenging to find
scholarships there are a lot of programs
to help you go back to school for
example here in tennessee there's a
program called tennessee reconnect where
it all offers help and funding and
guidance for adults who maybe did a
different career and want to go back and
get a four-year degree so i would start
looking there i would also consider
tuition assistance programs so
there are a lot of companies or
hospitals or labs that offer assistance
for you to go back and get a degree so
perhaps you can get it completely paid
for by an employer while still earning
some money absolutely and i was just
googling you know nursing programs in
ohio and seeing what it actually cost so
that's part of the homework is going
what does this cost where's the most
affordable place i can go you don't need
to go to the best nursing school in the
country
and then know that it's not going to be
a jump into the nursing field this is
going to take some time you're going to
have to really commit to this and that
might mean delaying this dream by a few
years keep working on hvac kill it you
guys are out of debt which is awesome
let's start saving up as much cash as
possible in order to cash flow this
while we do our homework and look at all
the programs and scholarships and
tuition assistance that are out there
and that gives us a clear game plan
christine i feel like a lot of people
just kind of wander in they go i don't
really know what this is gonna i'll just
take out loans it'll be easier
instead of just doing the hard work of
going okay what is this going to cost
let's make a plan to get there and debt
is off the table it's not an option and
that means we're going to get creative
and we're going to work really hard to
figure out how we're going to pay cash
for this well and it's a little bit of
work on the front end when you really
think about it it seems like it's just
easier to to just jump in and start
figuring it out later but it's like
actually if you take a two hour planning
session on a saturday and you lay this
out and you do the research and you see
all the options out there it can
literally save you thousands and
thousands of dollars in the long run
but i love that that line in the sand i
think i think gavin has a great position
starting saying hey i want this but i'm
not going into debt to do this that's
that's awesome that starts with that
decision we're rooting for you man thank
you so much for the question
all right open phones this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
kylie joins us up next in salt lake city
kylie welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
absolutely how can christina and i help
hey i just have a question we are
completely debt-free except for our
house we owe about 140 000 on it
and my question is
would it be
we
my dad built me this house 10 years ago
and so we have emotional ties to it he's
since passed away
but i am wanting to not work anymore and
stay home with my kids
and so we're wondering if we should sell
we we have quite a bit of equity in it
we built it in 2012.
and we're wondering if we should sell it
and buy a house outright with cash and
leave the community that we love and the
house that my dad built me
and um
pay for a house and cash and be able to
be a stay-at-home mom how much equity do
you have in this house
we have well it's currently appraised
for about 750
so what would that be that's awesome so
we're talking about 600
yeah
and what's about the price point you're
looking at for other houses in the
community you said it's in the same in
the same town
oh no we would have to leave our
community yeah
how much further out would you have to
go
about 30
20 30 miles away okay and does that
affect work at all
for your spouse well i i'm a hair
stylist i work out of my house and but
the goal is to not work
and so i would be giving that up
completely because my clientele is in my
community
um mostly in that i live is it an option
for my husband it wouldn't is it an
option for you guys to stay in the home
and still cover the mortgage and have it
be a reasonable portion of your
take-home pay
um
i well i would just have to work we
could stay in here you're saying you
couldn't afford it just on your spouse's
income
correct uh okay how much does your
husband of where we're we have young
kids he makes
he makes about 75 thousand a year
okay what's your mortgage payment
thirteen hundred dollars
okay and what's his uh take-home pay
he brings home about
1700 1800 every two weeks so every two
weeks okay so close to four grand a
month it doesn't seem like that's wildly
out of the ballpark is that on a 30-year
fixed rate mortgage or 15
that's on a 20.
on a 20. okay i'm wondering
if we can make these numbers work i
assume that's after he's investing you
guys said you're out of debt with an
emergency fund are you guys currently
investing right
um no he just puts 15 in his 401k
okay does that affect that take-home pay
yeah well that's what i mean that's what
his checks are every two weeks okay
about 1700 yeah i think if we can get
his income up just a little bit we can
stay in this house if this is if this is
the dream
well and just even tightening the budget
because when i hear 75k and a 1300
dollar payment that does seem doable
someone said the mortgage payment's
three grand i'd go oh my gosh this is
killing you guys or if he was making 40.
but yeah i don't see this as a huge
problem if we can just get his income up
a little bit
and get this house paid off
because it sounds like you really want
to stay there but you also really want
to stay at home and that's a tough
you're trying to weigh those two going
what's more important
um right i mean
at some point you may have to leave this
house and so at some point we have to
say goodbye and kind of grieve you know
the emotional attachment of this very
special home that your father built and
clearly did a great job
yeah and you said you want to stay home
with the kids do you currently um is
your salon outside of the home
no it's inside of my home i work about
three full days a week
do you think that you need to
it's starting to like cut into you know
their their sports and their
extracurriculars and
i wonder if you could kind of back
things down kind of gradually um
especially if you're you're kind of
feeling uncomfortable with the idea of
being
going from having your income to not and
that's obviously making you consider the
house situation and selling it could you
kind of back it down slowly maybe go
down to like one day a week or even a
half a day a week just you have a little
bit more buffer room how would that
extra yeah have you guys looked into
refinancing to a 15-year and seeing if
that actually lowers the payment because
of how much equity you have
no we haven't
should like that i didn't know about
that i would reach out to churchill and
just crunch some numbers with them and
see if we can get that further down
without extending the loan without
raising the interest rate on this but
that might be an option i don't see this
as a fire scenario where i'm going you
gotta sell the house that would be a
worse worst case scenario if this is
really stressing you guys out and things
are still too tight that's when i'd
start looking at that option yeah i
think there's the possibility for a lot
of creative solutions i love that we
look at this situation and it's like you
can do this you can do this you can try
all these different scenarios before you
have to sell this house that you love so
much big move it's costly and i'd only
recommend it if it really catapults you
you know further in the baby steps and
right now it's not really doing that and
this house is really special this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined by christina ellis today
and we're taking your calls triple eight
eight two five 825-5225
xavier joins us in jacksonville florida
xavier welcome to the show
hey how's it going thanks for having me
absolutely how can we help today
hey i just have a quick question um so i
love everything you guys do and thank
you very much i appreciate i've learned
so much from you guys that i wish they
would have talked to us in high school
um i'm 35 i'm actually calling on behalf
of my my mother she came to me with a
question about financial advice and i
really don't know what direction to send
her or what advice to give her
my father i'm sorry my parents had to
file for bankruptcy about 10 years ago
they bounced back from that got better
credit scores everything's uh was good
my mom has kept a separate ledger she's
great on that but unfortunately my dad
did dive back into about 40 thousand
dollars in credit card debt
including an auto loan and she had asked
me she's thinking about
i think refinancing her mortgage
their mortgage um and taking a cash out
option to pay off his debt does that
sound like a good idea because i don't
really know anything about that i don't
own a home yet um but if for some reason
i'm just getting bad vibes from it it
doesn't sound like a very smart
financial decision well you were a wise
young man and the fact that your mom
came to you for financial advice tells
me she knows that you have that kind of
wisdom and so you're right we never
advise a cash out refi unless there's a
divorce situation where you have to you
know let go of the money um so in that
situation i would say she's got to focus
on paying off this debt
that's the only way to pay off debt is
to pay off debt and this the cash out
refi is a shortcut but what it does is
set her
on a path backwards to paying off her
mortgage which means she's not going to
be able to retire with dignity
right and that's what i'm worried about
because you know they're 55 so you know
wanting to retire hopefully in the next
15 years i just i'm like i feel like
you're going to be eating into your
retirement it's just not a smart idea
and i personally have always worn away
from credit cards that have zero credit
card debt and so i'm still working on
baby step two but all right i just
wanted to make sure i gave her the right
uh advice on that so i do appreciate it
um how much do you know
what i paid off oh you said they have a
car loan
oh the auto loan yeah so my dad had an
auto loan for it was about uh 10 000 on
a truck i think if i remember correctly
the bank offered him a settlement of 4
000 to pay it off because unfortunately
he's been out of work for the last
couple of years um and they were just
they're one trying to repossess it but
two they're like listen give us four
grand and we'll call it even um you know
obviously settling for less than the
full balance
how do they do it
um i told him i said if she can get a
hold of the bank that would be the
smartest option to go with that and then
work on the credit cards later on um but
i i just felt like you know taking the
cash out i basically look at it as like
a cash advance on your house and it just
doesn't make sense you wouldn't do it on
a credit card don't do it on your house
hey have they taken financial piece
no they have not no i i personally have
just stumbled upon the whole ramsey
network in the last couple of months um
i recently got into a new profession
that i'm really loving and have
quadrupled my income and so i'm like
okay i need to you know do everything
the smart way and and really
you know make the right decisions from
for moving forward and so i
i have no credit card debt i actually
just sold my car a couple weeks ago
because my payments were like 900 a
month and i'm like i don't want it
anymore i have i have another um truck
that you know it's an old hooky but
you know 100 every couple a hundred
dollars every couple of uh weeks is
nothing compe you know for a random part
that might break versus the 900 that i
have to pay every month though well i
love you i'm crazy i love your
enthusiasm that's amazing and i would
just encourage you to take that raw
excited enthusiasm and share that with
your parents say hey i just found this
plan i am so excited about it i'm just
jazzed this is how my life is changing
this is what i've done with my income
and just encourage them to take this
journey with you because with your dad
going out and taking that extra debt
without your mom knowing it does sound
like there's kind of some mindset stuff
going on so you know the refinance all
these different things you know that
could kind of be a quick solution but i
think what really needs to happen is
some heart change and for him to really
buy into a program alongside your mom
especially so they can work together in
the next 10 to 15 years and really make
deep progress versus your mom kind of
having that fear of you know is he
really on board are we just trying to
figure out something really quick so we
don't you know we're not in debt in the
immediate term yeah you know live near
them
um yes yes i actually ended up having to
move back in with them uh just before
covid hit because they both lost their
jobs and so i was covering the mortgage
i was in school at the time i had to
drop out of school to work buku over
time to cover the mortgage and so i'm
hoping that one day i can go back but
for right now i just got my cdl and
things have been great in that so i am
blessed with that my mom before that
unfortunately has ms multiple sclerosis
and so there has been ups and downs with
her health and that was the big thing
that worried me i'm like okay what if
you refinance what if you do this what
if you do this and what if something
happens where you're in the hospital i'm
like it doesn't make any sense you guys
like i know i'm younger than you and i
know parents know best but it just
doesn't make sense like the numbers are
the numbers yeah well xavier i want to
do you
a solid here we're going to gift you
financial peace university to go through
with your parents i want you to sit down
every week or if you guys want to watch
more than that sit down watch all nine
lessons with them have some hard
conversations and be be their
cheerleader be that supportive voice
that says you guys can do this we're
going to get back to work we're going to
get our incomes up when we can obviously
your mom's health plays a huge part in
this and so it might take longer but if
they want to retire and not be stressed
about money instead be able to focus on
getting your health in order then this
is a huge step getting them completely
debt free so hang on the line austin
will pick up and we'll hook you up with
financial peace university as well as
our budgeting tool every dollar well i
think it's so cool that you're doing it
in this spot where you're actually going
through it with them this isn't a spot
where you know you're on baby step seven
and you're coming back and going this is
how you do it and the parents feel shame
and guilt and it becomes this
uncomfortable conversation you are
walking through this right now you are
jazzed you are on fire and i think if
you're just authentic with that that's a
whole different approach i think they're
way more likely to get on board when
it's coming from the spot of genuine
heart change where you're going through
it yourself you're motivated you're
excited and they can just jump on board
with you that's really cool way to go
xavier all right steven joins us up next
in dallas texas stephen welcome to the
show
hey there how are you doing great
what's going on with you
um so i'm trying to determine if um
i should i've got a taxable uh
investment account that i was set up
with and i've contributed to um for the
past few years
and it's uh almost enough to clear out
the mortgage oh it's awesome
now obviously there's some
tax implications right because it's you
know the growth we think is growth on it
um
would be taxable but i just kind of
trying to figure out okay should i do
this it's you know it's a substantial
amount enough about where um
just uneasy about it right to lose that
money that's sitting there available
how much is in that account
uh 200.
and how much is left on your mortgage
242
and i have the i have the
other
amount in my
checking
does that include your emergency fund or
could you clear this without touching
the emergency fund
without
wow the emergency fund would be separate
how long have these investments been in
there would you be looking at long-term
capital gain rates
uh they started in i started it in 2017.
oh great when is your last contribution
uh it's monthly it comes out okay
yeah personally so you'd have a lot less
capital gains because of how long it's
been sitting there which makes me feel
better and so it really depends on
what's your your income that you file
taxes with
it fluctuates but i would say it's safe
to say 240.
and that's single or do you have a
spouse single single or i mean i have a
spouse but that's a single income so
you're probably looking at uh 15
rate on the capital gains there
okay so i'd connect with a tax bro and
crunch the numbers of what you're gonna
owe but as long as you have that amount
set aside and you pay the taxes on that
dude pay off the mortgage that's amazing
okay well i appreciate it i uh
appreciate the uh additional
encouragement on it because it's uh hard
to part with that that's a lot of money
sitting there but you know what
freedom's on the other side of you
cashing that thing out paying off that
mortgage and that is priceless that's
super exciting and then you have a
fantastic income and it all stays with
you imagine that it all stays with
stephen and your hard work man it has
paid off your diligence
your consistency your discipline and
investing
that's inspiring way to go man we're so
so happy for you coming to a debt-free
scream why won't you i mean that'll be
fun right
yeah even if you use the investment
account that's an incredible incredible
achievement that most americans don't
even get to so we're proud of you man
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined today by
christina ellis this is the ramsey show
open phones triple eight eight two five
five two two five
lori joins us up next in spokane
washington lori welcome to the ramsay
show
first off i want to thank you for taking
my call and let you know you guys do a
great job oh thanks my question is
you're welcome my question is i live on
social security
and um i have a large amount of cash in
my savings account
um with the new law that's just come out
with the irs and everything i'm kind of
afraid of what's going to happen with
that money it's in a very low interest
account so i'm not really making a lot
should i take it out buy gold i really
i'm afraid of the stock market so i'm
kind of lost and asking for your help
well we appreciate the call lori how old
are you
i'm 62. okay and you're not working
no i'm currently on social security
disability okay what does that amount to
every month
about
14.67 all right and that's all the money
you have coming in
yes are you able to survive and put food
on the table and cover your bills
um yes i sold my house last year and i
bought a fifth wheel so i travel but i'm
afraid to leave that money in my account
i don't know what they're going to do
with it with the
digital currency thing they're talking
about and the irs stuff and how much
money is in that i can make sure that my
money's protected um a little over a
hundred thousand
all right
well i want to eat and i've got years a
rough ira for about 900
900 in the roth ira
yeah okay
and this is just in a general setting
yes okay
well for starters until we do something
more drastic with it you could put it in
a high yield online savings account
which would give you you know right now
the interest rates are sitting at about
1.7 2 somewhere around there what's your
money making right now okay
uh 0.1 i think okay so we can do better
than that the long-term solution would
be to connect with one of our smart
investor pros and make this money work
for you and get it into the stock market
i'm not talking about risky single
stocks we're not going to mess with gold
we're not going to mess with digital
currency we're going to put it in mutual
funds and index funds that are
diversified and what that means is we're
not investing in one single company or
one single thing we're investing across
a whole lot of things that have a proven
track record
okay but i would not put it in precious
metals gold's got a terrible rate of
return that's not going to get you
through retirement and the best way to
do it
is to create some cash flow off of that
hundred thousand and it could you know
with a ten percent return in the market
let's say that could create ten thousand
dollars worth of income for you for a
while
and lori i'm wondering what is what's
kind of the long-term plan in term of in
terms of housing you said you sold your
house and you're in a fifth wheel now
um is that is that how long do you think
you plan on living there
oh
you know as long as i can i'm sure
enjoying the traveling
um but there's going to come a point
where i'm not going to be able to
physically do this by myself so i'm
guessing
i just think another 10 to 15 years
maybe well that's that's another
spot you could put um the money is in
real estate i mean at some point if
you're not going to be living in a fifth
wheel it might be great to buy a little
condo somewhere it may not be huge with
a hundred thousand but you could buy
somewhere that could be somewhere you
could stay and live out you know the
rest of your life somewhere that's solid
and it's you're not gonna have to worry
about it eating into the rest of your
budget
how would you feel about buying property
well i i because i only make a limited
income um i'm not sure if i could if
that's enough to even be able to buy
property and have something left for
emergencies or anything like that is
that hundred thousand
is that everything to your name that
hundred thousand
yes sir okay so we need to set aside
three to six months of expenses you
don't have any debt of any kind
i have no debt i just my car insurance
and my
my fifth real insurance okay great and
you will include
so i would set aside everything is paid
for at least 10 or 15 000 of that and
the rest i would look at investing with
one of our smart investor pros into good
gross stock mutual funds index funds
that can grow at a much higher rate than
0.01 because that sucks
yeah yes it does and so um and do you
have a suggestion of who i may contact
or i mean it's hard to know anymore out
there who you can trust so
well i've got good news for you we have
an entire team here at ramsey that vets
investment professionals across the
country including in the spokane area
and so you can trust that they're going
to take good care of you i still want
you to interview a few of them and work
with the one that you have the best
chemistry with that you trust the most
and their job is to not tell you what to
do with this money it's to educate you
and make you feel confident in that
decision and so you can jump onto
ramseysolutions.com and click on trusted
pros
and you'll just enter your zip code and
it'll show you a list of about five pros
in your area and give them a call or
they'll contact you and we can start
from there but right now you know
sitting on the sidelines in fear is not
going to be a great plan to retire with
dignity and i want that for you and you
may need to look into affordable housing
because of your situation and see what
the options are
if we can't buy property
well i do fortunately have a friend that
owns a duplex and so she knows when i
get older the other half for me so in
that respect i think i'm sad that's what
friends that's sweet being homeless but
i do want to protect the assets that i
do have and if at all possible have them
grow
um
so that's kind of where i am
yeah and so you said ramsay
solutions.com
yes i'll make sure austin picks up and
we'll get you connected over to one of
our smart vester pros in your area who
can walk you through all of this and
make a plan for that money thanks so
much for the call i appreciate it manuel
joins us up next in san bernardino
manuel welcome to the show
hey thank you guys thanks for us and
answering my call
yeah absolutely
thank you yeah um i had a question um i
recently changed jobs
um
they're closer to my house they're
paying me a little bit more
but my question is that i had a 401k and
i had quite a bit of uh like about 18
000
but i have that money there so i don't
want to i wanted to switch it to either
a 401k there's a way to do that or you
said it's already in a 401k
yeah in my recent um job
is that a traditional 401k that it was
in yes not a roth okay
so what you want to look into is a
direct rollover that's the key word
there direct rollover to a traditional
ira
direct rollover yes and you can get in
touch with one of our smart investor
pros they can walk you through that help
you do all of that i did the same thing
when i had an old 401k from a previous
employer and they helped me roll that
over into an ira
and that's what you want to do because
that puts you in control you have way
more investing options and it's not
sitting with this old company over there
and that can that money can grow for you
with no tax implications that's why you
want to do a direct rollover you don't
want to cash it out put it in your bank
and then do a money move with it
yeah because i was the um the actually
the agency where i was having my 401k
that i could just
withdraw a little i mean nothing would
drop but like invest little by little or
just the whole thing at all
but i don't know if there's like taxes
deducted from there or
stuff like that i would just roll it
over do a direct rollover to that ira
that's going to be your best bet if your
new employer has a 401k let's just start
fresh and start investing future income
into that and if there's a roth option
that's even better do you know if they
have that
no i don't know about that um yeah but
i know they have a 401k
the traditional one but i just didn't
want to roll it over to them i wanted
actually every since i started listening
to ramsey
i
wanted to open up a roth ira
i love it well you can do that but
that's going to have tax implications so
you can open up a new roth ira and
invest future income into that and what
we say is match beats roth beats
traditional so if your workplace has a
match in that 401k let's start there
then let's move to a roth ira you can
fund that the max is about six thousand
dollars this year and then if you have
money left over outside of that to get
to that fifteen percent number that we
wanna hit you can go back to the 401k
and invest there
okay so just
directly just roll it over to um
the thing is i don't really know all
right i understand the basics
of actually how investing works out i'm
not too much of a pro that's all right
and our smart investor pros will educate
you they'll walk you through what that
process looks like and if you invest 15
into that 401k at your age you will be a
millionaire man and that's the goal it
doesn't have to be complicated you don't
need to be in a wolf of wall street to
do this stuff so go to
ramseysolutions.com get connected with
one of our smart fester pros they'll
help you make a plan they'll help you do
the direct rollover that's what they're
there for thanks so much for the call
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books i'm george campbell joined
by christina ellis thank you guys so
much we'll be back with you
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print entre leadership
podcast joined today by best selling
author and fellow ramsey personality
christina ellis and we are excited to
take your call about life and money the
number to dial is triple eight eight two
five five two two five don't be shy do
it
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
andrea joins us in denver colorado to
kick off this hour andrea welcome to the
show
hi thanks for taking my call absolutely
how can we help
um i had a question about
my husband and i've future real estate
plan so right now we are in a condo that
we own a hundred percent awesome um
we have fifty thousand dollars in our
savings account and our plan was to live
here for another two years
and just keep stacking away money
and then keep the condo that we have
and
if we have like 100 150 if not hopefully
more
buy like a single family house because
we do have a couple of kids
and
rent this house out
now we would
have
you know a small mortgage on whatever
house we purchased after that
but we would
get gazelle intense again and pay that
off very quickly so what do you think of
that plan
i mean you guys are crushing it that's
incredible i like where this is going so
the condos paid off what's it worth
it's worth about 360 to 270. and what do
you think you could rent it for
um oh gosh we haven't even thought about
that um
probably between
sixteen hundred to two thousand a month
love it
and how much is the new house gonna cost
we're hoping to stay below the 550 range
and what's your household income
um we net um 110 okay
so the only worrisome part is you said
you're gonna have 150 to put down on the
new house
i'm hoping more but that's you know
being conservative yes okay because that
leaves you guys with a 400 000 deficit
that you'd have to take a mortgage out
on and my concern is that's a whole
that's a that's a lot of payment
uh from your take-home pay
okay
so i might be looking at either delaying
that purchase
to be further out to where you could put
you know 350 400 down and have 150 000
mortgage i'd feel a lot better about
that plan or we look at finding a more
affordable single family home which may
be very difficult in the denver colorado
area right
right we're in grand junction but that
was the closest city so okay it's a lot
less but it's still you know it's
but there's not a lot of great single
family homes for 250 in that area
no no okay
so that's yeah i mean i would go you can
jump onto our mortgage calculator at
ramseysolutions.com and crunch those
numbers but
this is a good plan if the payment of
the new house is going to be a quarter
of your take-home pay on a 15-year fixed
and that will dictate how much money
down you would need and if that's 150
and you still have the emergency fund
and you're still investing 15
fantastic but if not it just means
delaying well and i mean the condo it's
nice to have a real estate investment
it's nice to have something that's
earning money but there is also the
option of selling it and getting a lot
closer to having a much larger down
payment and then just having your
primary residence completely paid off
which i know that would feel pretty
fantastic
what do you think about that plan of
selling it and using that and maybe
paying cash for your primary residence
um i think that because the condo is in
such a good area
i would rather stay here longer and just
save more than rather than selling it so
even just
delaying yeah if that makes sense
absolutely i mean the rent that you
would make you're looking at you know
maybe 20 grand a year so it's not like
life-changing money it's great i'm a big
fan of of real estate investing but i
want you to do it in a way that isn't
going to add stress to your life to
where you're now a landlord you've got a
mortgage again it's a big mortgage
because a 400 000 mortgage on a 15-year
fixed is gonna be a big portion of your
income and so i just want you to do this
with wisdom it sounds like you're
wanting to do that you're wanting to do
it the right way and if that means
delaying you're okay with that
well you guys have obviously shown that
you're willing to make the sacrifices
the fact that you already have a 100
paid off condo you have 50 000 in
savings you guys are
tight with your money and you're doing a
great job so how old are you two
my husband's 34 and i will be 33 on
wednesday oh my goodness
happy early birthday you guys are
killing i love seeing people in the
early 30s making wise money moves like
this it's awesome inspiring stuff and i
also just love that she's she's just
very relaxed about it i feel like right
now in the real estate world people are
so stressed there is no frenzy in her
voice right that is that's just
refreshing to hear because i feel like a
lot of people in these scenarios are
very much like i'm in a condo i need to
get out now what should i do and there's
a lot of like panic around real estate
just in general right now so i think
it's just
she's in such a great place it's very
refreshing to hear it was calming to me
yeah so thank you andrea all right james
joins us up next in hartford connecticut
james welcome to the show
thank you very much for taking my call i
really appreciate it um
how you both doing today we are so thank
you for asking i appreciate that james
what's going on with you
so
first of all i'd like to start out by
saying that dave has completely changed
uh both uh
the life for myself and my wife um we've
gone from being in 30 000 debt to being
debt free to having a fully funded
emergency fund awesome but we've been
kind of dave-ish and we've had a
discussion because it comes
down to costco and i know you guys are
big supporters of costco big kirkland
signature fan over here i got the
sweatshirt and everything my man thank
you very much
that's great to hear uh it's one of our
favorite experiences of the week but
what it comes down to is
we
have not
i regret to say
gotten rid of the
costco credit card because there's a
year
an annual fee
and my wife's argument is that well
we spend money at costco we get the cash
back on the credit card so it covers our
annual fee
and then i love that she's right there
next to you being like give him the full
story james we are trying to
yeah
we're trying to not be on stage but she
is right here with me
and we
yeah i i love it and i love her too and
i and i appreciate her opinion and it's
i i don't want to be davish i want to
completely commit to this lifestyle
because it it really has from the point
of giving to every aspect of our life
um it's changed everything we we've
never been so comfortable even in these
most turbulent times but
we have not
gotten rid of the costco credit card
with the cash back
because of the annual fee and she's like
he covers the annual fee and we get like
seven hundred dollars a year cash back
we pay no interest so for can you pay it
off every month right
sure no i i we need you to weigh in on
this because i i have no argument i have
nowhere to go with it i cannot wait to
give you my opinion and this is rare but
i'm gonna hold you over the break so
hang on the line we're going to come
back to you and i want to hear from your
wife's side of the story because you're
convinced but if she's right there we
got to talk to her about costco this is
my favorite call of the day so hang on
the line james we're going to have a
conversation about costco about credit
cards about rewards cash back all of it
right here on the ramsay show stick
around
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show
if you missed it just before the break
we were talking to our friend james in
hartford connecticut
and they are debt free fully funded
emergency fund doing the ramsey plan but
ish because
they can't get rid of the costco credit
card
it's too emotional so we're going to go
back to james here and uh and see what
his wife has to say who is also on
speakerphone james are you with us
yes yeah and i have my wife shannon here
shannon you always hear her perspective
on this whole thing yeah shannon all
right lay it out for us what do you love
about this card that it's like under
your pillow at night you're snuggling it
okay so my thing is is we don't ever pay
interest we always make sure that we
only spend what we can afford but then
yeah at the end of the year like i get
my gas cheaper every time i get gas i
save money you know occasionally on
everything that we buy including milk
bread eggs which we have now
gone to costco for because of the cost
of the grocery store in opposition to
what costco charges
and so at the end of the year we usually
get costco does two different checks and
at the end of the year when we total it
all up it becomes anywhere from like a
700 to 900
um
increase in money i'll say so even if we
spend 150 dollars
in
our fee for our costco card
we still get back anywhere between seven
and nine hundred dollars interest free
we have never paid interest we've never
paid a late fee
and we still save on the goods that we
would buy every week for our home for
our family
so for me i kind of look at it as well
every week we buy gas we save money on
gas every week we buy milk bread eggs
laundry detergent things like that
i always i'm a coupon shopper so i
always save money
and at the end of the year we get that
bonus and my husband wants to cancel the
card and me i'm like but it takes me you
know i have to work two full shifts at
the hospital to gain that seven to nine
hundred dollars and it's two days a week
i don't have to work
and to get that extra money and it's
like you know it's just in my sense it's
free money
and he disagrees um all right james your
turn to weigh in well here's why so
she actually just made a very good point
earlier i didn't even have to say it she
said i went to the grocery store the
other day and i brought the cash because
we have our grocery store envelope yes
thank you dave ramsey for that we have
our grocery cash envelope and she said i
i had 120 in there but i also had
another 28
in cash already in there so she thought
that would be plenty of money next thing
you know was like 130 and it killed her
to throw that 130 out there she couldn't
believe that we were spending that much
on the groceries and there was that
moment of pause where she felt like
maybe should we spend this or should we
not so i thought
maybe there's been these moments where
we're at costco
and we potentially would have had that
same moment but because we're putting it
on the costco credit card
we just
you know said you know what we'll pay it
at the end of the month which we do
because we you know at the end of the
month we do the tally and we decide you
know what goes
into our savings what goes into you know
if we have any extra you know top off
our roth you know we'll do that but
maybe we would not have made that
purchase had we gone in there with cash
with the the regular costco membership
so that's why james makes a good point
shannon you got to give it to him there
it hurts when you spend cash you know
why those employees are at the doors to
check your receipt
why
because they have to make sure you spend
200 at costco legally that's what
they're there for they know shannon
wouldn't steal you only spent 50.
what you bought one thing at costco you
bought what laundry detergent
how often are you at costco you should
just work there at this point this is
impressive no
she's always there
yeah she is she's always there at the
door calculating our expenses how about
how about we have a compromise here
shannon what if okay we cut up the card
okay
and then we get the executive costco
membership that's what i have you have
that which gives you two percent back
already without the credit card and four
percent on gas okay the four percent on
gas uh now that gas is calming down i
mean that doesn't add up to that much a
year how much are you guys spending on
gas every week
it's not that much however i do fill up
my gas tank i have an suv i do fill up
my gas tank once a week at costco and i
do save an average of about 12 to 14
cents per gallon
what i'm saying let's say i mean you got
the suv what 100 bucks to fill up 120
no it's like 78 78 okay so let me just
do some math because we're here we're
already deep in this costco thing you
spend four thousand dollars a year 78
dollars a week times 52 is 4 000
you said you get 4 percent all right
we're making 160 off of this
yeah
how much do you guys make a year
uh like two
something total probably you make over
200 000 and we're hanging on to a card
to get a hundred dollars
i mean i'm just saying you guys are good
now the truth is like is this going to
take your life to keep this card around
no you can still retire with dignity
you're going to be millionaires you make
a great income you're doing the ramsey
plan almost and so well the thing is is
it's new i mean we're newly found i'm 47
my husband is 40 and we are newly found
right ramsey it's like two years it's
only been about two years and you've
already made this much progress
all while hanging on to a credit card so
now imagine we let go just do this
challenge for me shannon what if
you don't even cut it up tomorrow give
it two weeks and spend hard cold cash at
costco without touching the card you're
gonna miss out on the precious cash back
right
but i want you to see how much you save
in spending the original amount you
spent by doing that and you can call the
show back austin will remember you he'll
never forget james and shannon from
hartford
and
because i'm a costco member i've got the
executive membership ramsey covers the
cost for our team members my wife works
here so they're nice enough to cover the
executive membership and we just got our
our big check for the year of like a
hundred eleven dollars in cash back and
it doesn't change my life i don't go
like well i'm gonna spend a thousand
dollars more at costco to get the cash
back but james is right there's a
subconscious piece to this that when you
spend hard cold cash it physically hurts
especially at these wholesale clubs
where everything's expensive
i can i just pause and say i love this i
feel like there should be a new thing on
the ramsey show settle the debate
we have so many like one spouse calls in
and it's like i wonder what the other
spouse is thinking but y'all just
brought something new and i love that
you guys are in on this usually one
spouse calls in and the other spouse
isn't there to defend themselves but
shannon is here to defend her goodness
no i'm here yeah
i love him here we're definitely we're
in this together we did this we started
this together we are in this together
and we've also got our you know 20 and
24 year old sons involved where we are
trying to get them 100 you know ramsay
all the way so do you have them opening
credit cards
do what do you have them opening credit
cards
no
no not at all why not go from ish i want
to go from ish
which is a wish to dave all the way so
that's where we're at right now so
shannon why not have all the kids open
up as many credit cards as possible and
get all the cash back as possible no see
i disagree with that
i do disagree with that but costco is
the only place that we actually
spend a certain amount of money like i
won't go to a store just because they
offer you know a discount or a cash i
won't just use my credit card for that
like i don't do that but costco because
we get so much cash back at the end of
the year we do a lot with giving we do a
lot with we did make-a-wish this year we
do you know
food banks we do christmas clubs we do
all sorts of things where we give back
because you know my husband when he
started this with us because it was all
him i will say it was all james 100 dave
ramsey full in
we do give back and we believe in that
so it's kind of like you know well if we
have this extra money it's more that we
can we can give and it is kind of nice
to get that check back or to even even
if even if i you know was one day at the
store and you have that check you say
okay well today's groceries we don't
have to pay for because we've paid for
it essentially all year round by not
paying any interest not paying any fees
our 100 and whatever dollar amount
costco charges was covered and now
they've given us back money for being a
good you're swimming sweet people well i
just want to hang out with james and
channel they're awesome here do me
another solid go listen to the fine
print episode 2 the true cost of credit
card rewards you might find out some
fascinating things in that episode that
i did on that hope it changes your mind
but if not you guys are gonna live but i
want you to go all in on this plan
because that's where the true life
change happens that's where you make
decisions differently because you're
spending your own money instead of the
banks thanks so much for the call guys
that was a good time this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
so
hmm
[Music]
well folks all of us here at ramsay know
that you've had enough stress lately
when it comes to the rising cost of gas
and groceries you might feel trapped in
a dead-end career your relationships
might need improvement
enough is enough you deserve a break and
that is why we brought back the ramsey
10 sale on our number one best-selling
books in tools but the sale is available
for just three more days so if you're
ready to say you know what i'm done
living this way if you want to hit the
reset button on your life you can take
advantage of some of our best selling
products and tools to do that
including the baby steps which is what i
use to climb out of debt and build
wealth we also have the total money
makeover know yourself know your money's
on there you can also pick up questions
for humans couples edition if you need
to reconnect with the spouse christina
this is very hard for me to do because
we get home you're tired you just want
to sit on your phone on social media and
scroll right oh man we love the
questions for humans couples edition we
actually did that on our date night
recently we've got kids and it's so easy
teacher's pet where's john deloney when
you need him he's gonna give you a gold
star but it's so easy as a parent to
like when you go out on your date night
you're just talking about your kids and
you're talking about everyday life and
this like actually challenges you to
have deep real culture most
conversations how was your day good how
was your day fine what are we doing for
dinner i don't know what do you want to
do that's like 80 of marriage right or
nagging like we got to do laundry you're
going to you get the i did dishes last
time and so this is a great way to
actually connect as a couple that's on
there as well dave's a brand new book on
personal growth the momentum theorem is
also on there if you want to start
making changes uh for for everything you
need in life and this is the cost of a
burrito these days 10 bucks that's
amazing
so there's only three days left to take
advantage of this and we're offering a
free financial coaching call with any
purchase that is worth the 10 alone
that's amazing
you can talk with a ramsey preferred
coach about your specific money
questions and plans with that free
financial coaching call so get it before
the sale ends go to ramseysolutions.com
and check out all of the products
included in the 10 sale all right jean
joins us up next in atlanta gene welcome
to the show
hi hi how are you
um good
i guess how are you we are doing well
how can we help today
i yes i um just recently got a
relationship and um
uh we i own the house uh my my name is
on the mortgage and a few years ago um
my boyfriend had pressured me to put his
name on the deed
and now that i'm in the house by myself
um
i don't
i don't know how to get his name off the
deed so that
i'm kind of upside down in it um
i heard rachel i just started watching
y'all last week and i heard rachel say
that if you're more than 50 if your
mortgage is more than 50
of your income than your house poor
and so i've been scrambling trying to
figure out what i need to do i'm afraid
that
the house might go into foreclosure
because i can't sell it because his name
is on the deed
i'm so sorry gene so is he out of the
picture now
yeah he was removed from the home um i
was in an abusive relationship with him
i'm so sorry
thank you are you okay now are you safe
yes i i just got back a couple months i
mean last week actually
okay i had stayed out of the house for
two months um
but he still hasn't moved his things out
so are you getting any help
professionally from a counselor
any support mental health
no okay i can't afford it right now i'm
just trying to figure out what to do
with the house i'm you know i'm i'm
paying a mortgage i mean credit card
debt
um that has built up over the few years
that we were together and so um i'm
trying to figure out you know i'm kind
of robbing peter to pay paul right now
do you have a pen and paper nearby
i do okay
write this word down quit claim deed
that's what you're gonna need him to
sign
in order to be able to sell the house
i've looked that up and i don't think
he's going to do it
well that at that
point you need to take him to court
he wants me i can't afford to even go to
court
it's that bad of the situation
well we need him to sign this quick
claim deed in order to go through with
this process and you do that with your
escrow company your local title company
there in the in the atlanta area and
what are they saying nobody think nobody
there's my mortgage company says i have
to um that's a deed problem and
the lawyers that i've called are
basically saying that they you know it's
a silver matter
are you able to get a public defender
i haven't been calling public defenders
and um
well at least the ones that i've called
were through the domestic violence
um people and
you know they don't know and they can't
reference me they just they call
you know uh
i just called somebody today and they
just told me that that was a legal
matter for civil litigation
i'm so sorry gene this is a messy
situation
yeah my heart goes out to you jane i do
wonder um you said you worked with a
domestic violence shelter what kind of
resources have they offered
well they were able to get my life
changed uh so far
um but i've i've talked to them about it
and even the lawyer there
they just you know they're just domestic
violence lawyers but it's like i either
need a real estate lawyer or or
like i said the civil litigation
well i do wonder if um if some of the
attorneys that are within that shelter
could recommend any other attorneys that
would perhaps work with you on a pro
bono situation
they just kind of put it back into my
hands to to find out and um he wants
my ex wants me to to drop the
restraining orders
but
what is that going to do for you
other than put you in danger
yeah
so i and i'm not speaking with him i
mean
during the threats he would say he would
give me back the house but he hasn't
said anything about it
now
how many um so you connected with one
domestic violence shelter are there any
other
yeah i did call another one who gave me
the name of a lawyer but the lawyer that
i spoke to told me that she was um for
marriages um uh she's a you know a
marriage lawyer not and she said my
because it was a boyfriend and not a
spouse
yes
um
well we're going to have to beat down
the doors of some of these public
defenders and get someone to fight for
you in a court of law to get him to sign
this quick claim to you and have a judge
go you're signing this thing or they're
going to go after him that seems to be
your only option at this point because
we can't sell the house without getting
the quick claim deed and here you are
trying to afford this mortgage and so
you need to at least contact your lender
and say listen here's the situation i
can't afford this mortgage you can
foreclose if you want to and i want to
sell this thing but i can't until he
signs a quick claim deed so i'm in kind
of a conundrum here
have you explained that to them
yeah i did call them
a few months ago and i um told them the
situation and and they were saying that
i would probably need to call a deed
lawyer
yeah have you done that
yeah but they gave me the number to
another lawyer and um
they said that
we would probably have to be forced to
sell the house and skip the proceeds
yeah well gene i'm so sorry you're going
through this i wish we could help
further what i am going to do is give
you a free financial coaching session
with someone in your area who can dig
deeper than we can on a quick radio call
here so hang on the line austin's going
to pick up and we're going to give gift
that to you
and it'll be about an hour and they'll
walk you through
all the resources available in their
area they'll be more knowledgeable than
we are about what's going on in the
atlanta area
but it sounds like there's only one
route here and it's to get a lawyer
who's willing to do this pro bono get a
public defender someone who was willing
to do this
since you don't have the money to cover
it uh to get him to sign but that's the
only way out of this thing with a quick
claim to eat him that is a legal
document saying that he is part owner in
this house and without that we can't
sell the house and so that is the a1 and
i hate that you have to go fight all
this after going through what you went
through i cannot imagine
but that's the situation we find
ourselves in i would also encourage you
to reach out to some mental health
professionals who work on a sliding
scale because there are some out there
i've had friends who've gone to
counseling for ten dollars because
that's all they could afford but you do
have to find them that work on a sliding
scale i think that could really help you
process some of this trauma and pain
that you've been through
well hang on the line gene austin will
pick up we will get you connected with
that financial coach and if there's
anything else we can do for you along
the way to get you out of this awful
situation please call us back we are
here for you this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day galatians 6 9
let us not become weary in doing good
for at the proper time we will reap a
harvest if we do not give up
mark twain said do the right thing it
will gratify some people and astonish
the rest
ain't that the truth
i'm george campbell joined by christina
ellis and we've been talking a lot about
student loan forgiveness and it's you
know spun up a whole bunch in the news
cycle and we found this article
from msn and buzzfeed people who regret
their student loans are sharing what
they make now and it's heartbreaking and
this speaks to the fact that
so many kids that i talk to that you've
talked to go well christina i'll take
out student loans because i'm going to
make like a ton of money when i graduate
i'll be able to pay it back so easily
and we have some real people
showing us that that is not quite the
truth right well what's sad is that a
lot of loan officers a lot of people
when kids encounter them at the college
they say hey it's going to be easy to
pay this back you're going to get this
awesome job after graduation and these
stories highlight that that's not always
true yeah let's read a few just to
really brighten up your day here all
right one person said i was a single mom
of two small children was told over and
over that college was the only way out
of poverty well got my degree and still
make less than fifty thousand a year i
currently owe one hundred and thirty
thousand i'll never be able to pay it
off or purchase a home i'm 52 i've no
idea how i'll retire or even live once i
can't work anymore
this next one says i'm about to turn 65
i have over a hundred thousand dollars
owed in student loans and regret having
gone to college as my earnings are sixty
thousand dollars yearly i have had to
file bankruptcy and can't afford to
retire because i have a chronic health
condition it will be paying student
loans until i die this debt should be
removed for senior citizens oh man
here's another one my teacher's salary
in southeast missouri was 30 000 a year
student loan total with interest 66 000.
in june i became a social worker making
36 000 a year this is brutal yeah this
one says i regret going to veterinary
school between undergrad and vet school
i have
360 000 in student loans i make 125 000
and i'll end on this one i have a ba in
telecommunications making 45k i'm in
debt for
139k when i graduated 13 years ago my
debt was 115. i've been making payments
all of those 13 years
smh which for those of you over 35 means
shaking my head
there we go wow this is dark stuff
christina and well it's led to a lot of
people
just going i'm just not gonna worry
about this because it's too much to
worry about i can't handle the stress of
it right and one especially with the
pandemic pause a lot of this has not
it's kind of been out of sight out of
mind so people haven't had to worry
about it and yes there's forgiveness now
but these stories highlight that there
there are still people in a lot of pain
with a lot of anxiety and a lot of debt
still so we've seen this tick tock trend
recently called the ostrich method where
people basically are thinking that the
best idea is to just stick their head in
the sand and kind of not think about
their you know this is like it's like
when you played hide and seek and you
just put your hand in front of your eyes
and you were like well if i can't see
them they can't see me
it doesn't work like that does it so
here's what the article from us today
says about the ostrich method yeah it
says relatable jokes about ignoring
student debt and dodging student loan
payments are popular across social media
after all the pause on federal student
loan payments has been extended multiple
times over the past two president over
the two presidential administrations
during the ongoing coronavirus pandemic
and many borrowers haven't had to make
payments for nearly two and a half years
the two plus year hiatus hasn't stopped
for social media users from joking about
how they'd like to avoid any and all
payments but what would happen if the
freeze on student loans is lifted and
you didn't pay people are asking
so what's happened is for two and a half
years we haven't made payments and so
everyone's gone well it's been two and a
half years i'm used to not making
payments what if i just kept not making
payments even when they become due
that's a scary thought well here's what
happens if um if you miss a federal
student loan payment it's considered
delinquent so that's the starting point
not good and remember you signed a
contract that says you're going to pay
this money back with interest and if you
don't uphold your end of the bargain
there are penalties associated on top of
the interest and then your loan can go
into what's known as default
which many many people do which then
damage damages your credit which you
know our feelings about the credit score
we say you don't need the credit score
system but a bad credit score will hurt
you we want you to have no credit score
because you don't touch debt
and this goes on christina this is not
fun because once it goes into default
your hit to your credit's not the only
consequence you also lose repayment plan
options you face other penalties and
then
the government can garnish your wages
and they can withhold your tax refunds
the child tax credit they can withhold
social security payments so this is
gonna follow you forever it's not gonna
go away there's not gonna be a magic
wand where they go well it's been 10
years and christina hasn't paid this is
something you can't even bankrupt on no
you can't run away from this situation
and i think what is so concerning about
this pause and
the fact that students are even having
these questions there's a lot of
students who graduated during the
pandemic they haven't paid their loans
this is their first experience with
money and the commitment of having to
pay something back and it's just been
paused and extended so it's easy to kind
of fall into that mindset of like maybe
this is the way things are maybe i don't
have to be responsible for you know the
things that i said i would do and that's
just a scary way to set out on your
financial journey yeah and many people
have not been budgeting for this of
course because they haven't been making
payments and so it is gonna be a dark
day when all of a sudden they go time to
pay the piper and you go oh my gosh six
hundred dollars eight hundred dollars a
month for these payments i just found
all of my old student loan documentation
when i was back home in boston my
parents said here's all your childhood
memorabilia and over half of it was just
student loan
bills that were coming in the mail
and more marketing from sallie mae about
how great you know they were called
smart option loans that feels like it
should be a legal smart option they're
marketing this like well there's a
battle of bad loans we're the good loan
out there
and so
this is scary stuff you can also lose
eligibility for additional federal
student aid you may not be able to buy
or sell assets like real estate uh there
can be legal action against you you can
get sued and if you still are like okay
that doesn't seem so bad please go watch
the borrowed future documentary or
listen to the borrowed future podcast
where we interview
a student loan attorney
and it is frightening it is a moment
i'll never forget in the documentary
where she says that the lenders are
basically saying give me your pound of
flesh and the way she says it has stuck
with me it is seared in my memory memory
from beverly and uh i kind of got chills
like the tingles down my arm you can't
ignore this boogie monster and it is
under your bed and the only way to do it
is to flash the light and go how much do
we owe and how are we going to pay this
off right that's it yeah you got to face
it i mean even if so now it's been just
extended till december and i would
encourage you don't use that time to
just do the ostrich method and stick
your head in this hand look at it now
start budgeting for it get that payment
back in your life and start you know
actually tackling it this is the best
time to be paying down your student
loans because the money is actually
going to principal versus interest so
this is when you can make the most
progress
yeah i remember the stories are just
coming back from when i did the borrowed
future podcast and you know talking to
a woman that was older who was going i'm
worth more dead than alive at this point
and the student loans just going to go
to the grave with me and my balance was
90 and now it's 120.
and so especially these income-based
repayment plans are actually hurting a
lot of americans because they're not
even touching the balance the balance
keeps growing because they're only
making you pay this much and they're
acting like they're your friend for
doing it right and yet the balance grows
and grows and grows like a cancer it's
terrible well it's like we've normalized
keeping student loans around for years
we've normalized this being a 20 to 25
year journey and we say that that does
not have to be the case we've had people
walk through these doors at ramsey
solutions with tons of debt and
typically the average person pays off
their student loans in 18 to 24 months
so i don't want you to just buy into
this lie but you have to keep these
loans in your life forever you can get
rid of them i actually recently created
a course called the ultimate guide to
getting rid of your student loan debt
and it's to help people find that
motivation find that drive and the
actual tools and resources and practical
guidance to get that out of your life
for goods it's actually free for ramsey
plus members and if you're not a ramsay
plus member you can find it at
christinaellis.com
start i love that well the key is here
number one get riled up because if we
keep ignoring it then nothing's going to
happen our life will continue to stay
the same and we'll live a life of media
rocket mediocrity and debt so do
something about this do the debt
snowball follow a plan get riled up
don't wait on washington to fix this
okay folks this is on us this is on the
parents to have conversations early and
often with our kids about how we're
going to make a plan to go to school
debt free it can be done yes well that
puts this hour of the ramsey show in the
books my thanks to my co-host christina
ellis all the folks in the booth austin
ben james zack andrew and you america we
appreciate you listening in until next
time spend wisely save intentionally and
give generously
[Music]
do you love a good dave rand want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you